[Music]
[Laughter]
it's gonna be a great night relief
aren't you these [__] don't
know and if you don't know now you know
oh my god
it's gonna be a heavy-duty night boys
and girls strap on your [__] bones
we got the weed to kill Hitler in
Argentina you understand me
this is this [__] right here tonight
that almost killed me
[Music]
we [__] around tonight tie your
grandma title don't come up it's all
over Jim Jones is showing up tonight
with kool-aid and [__] gorilla
biscuits and all this [__] you need on
Monday night you got Monday Night
Football
[__] Dancing with the Stars oh [__]
wish you were here [__] it's
that type of night
kick that [__] mule [__] look
at that cloud of smoke when was the last
time you saw that that's a [__]
spirit of debt that's the reefer was
smoking tonight it's called Paris don't
make me remind you I'm saying the
medical must hear you said there was a
medic coming
[Music]
oh [__]
[__] stuck with running a
[__] charity here you hesitated
[__] bastard a [__] we ready
for another one
Oh [__] almost popped out your
[__] lung you see nothing we ain't
stopping this party do you got my patch
[Music]
oh [__] Martin Sheen in Apocalypse Now
coming out of the jungle a death that's
what's crack-a-lackin' on a Monday night
[__]
it's your uncle Joey coming right into
your [__] you into the hemisphere
Pink Floyd wish you were here and don't
get better than this you know I'm saying
if you think of it becoming a suicide
bomber tonight's your lucky night this
is the I don't cattle give a [__] you
take your little car battery you put it
to your plug I don't know how to [__]
you do it whatever it's the first night
of Passover we're bringing it direct as
usual perennial showed up with this
[__]
oh good googly moogly and we showed up
with this right here
glue the name of it what do you see that
[__] death star makes me want to
scratch my [__] eyebrows ones last
time you smoke weed and your eyebrows
with you huh that's right coming at you
at a Monday night look at my [__]
body of death I'm just wondering if this
is close for Passover I don't even think
about that stores that he is Ali Baba
jr. and the 22 [__] thieves well
there's no [__] Holly Baba bid
good to see you [__] I'm strong
light no stars till Sunday and then
we're gonna really get this [__]
party started I hope you see why you
interrupted me I'm talking to these poor
[__] people here listen
we're going deep on Sunday and I don't
give a [__] go to your dentist your
family dinners grab an envelope other
people eat the chocolate and we're gonna
do the podcast but for right now what's
happened it's a beautiful night to be
alive you got through it right you would
read Monday what the [__] here we are it
could be 11 o'clock it could be 8
o'clock in California we got wish you
were here on with doing bong Exley's
here what's up buddy you ready you're
looking at you ready for abundant that's
what I was thinking we'll give you a
little time let me finish them I don't
want you people to think I'm living like
a [__] communist
[Music]
you think it is what's wrong with this
[__] nut five years he's still [__]
that's nothing that's if used the Train
like you're supposed to the last few
weeks 2200 will be nothing if you
understand me then you over there
[__] for gays and stars first you
started with the [__] KitKat and now
you switch it over I watched those tapes
he's eating stars giggling he don't know
he's slipping them under the table I
guarantee if we check his mailbox and
what Amazon deliberate the last month
there's a book in there how to be a
magician this is the one this is the one
right here you'll love this wreath
everybody I take us through correctly
breathing than just that last thing man
doctor beliefs in the house
that's cool that's not all the way there
you go
go for broke go for broke let's go there
you go nothing see like a [__]
soldier it [__] you think you're dealing
with here think we're over here playing
games hiding fake games
[__] no we're smoking what counts
[__] thank you for coming into
our little living room man this evening
excuse me while I drink a little hard
water that's water it's faster for you
no I blow by the [__] you understand
me get your [__] together
feast on this Dave Gilmour katana that's
what you need to be [__] listened to
forget about me
[Music]
oh [__] you're taking a [__] this is a
psychological drill of the south
I keep living in the [__] sand what
are you kidding me who [__] arms
meeting are you [__] kidding me you
think I'm just sitting here who'll be
doing listen the [__] you know
whatever we're taking it to the next
level we wet this [__] monster BAM we
still got fall we got the [__] Paris
we got the Death Star the edibles are
done there's two left left the fun will
get a new batch this week start one been
there for us this day one they'll be
there on day 29 if you're at sunset
Herbal in the area stop and get yourself
three stars tell the chicks all that sun
solaire Blanco Joey Sancho 4/20 week you
do what you want you got a perennial you
tell them uncle Joey send you or you
gonna see get a star a debt you tell
them for choice a either way you don't
lose anyway you're looking good
[__] I haven't seen you in a
couple days you guys are looking sharp
today what you [__] ready to go you
got your merengue shoes on shine on you
crazy diamond what's up merengue shoes
wait you don't hang out with Merengues
shoes I'm gonna give a shout-out to my
main little brother Timmy 8c me and
Julian Timmy
Tilly's senior and julian understand me
you gotta salute the whole [__]
family you're gonna show up you know
your Lee's gotta mention the captain
something you [__]
Tim eh that's his name to me it's all
you need to know this room is like an a
a meeting all right
no last names just front you say listen
to me a to this cat that's it it's a
beautiful night [__] if you're
Nadine get the [__] off this thing you
little [__]
go do your biography home with a low
jerk ball to a [__] internet thing
don't be watching Uncle Joe and a
valuable information in your feed I'm
sorry what the [__] don't go or whatever
what do you prefer one of these perverts
watch ya pornhub go to point up they'll
hook you up you can whack off they got
midgets and me whatever the [__] you
like me I'm sitting here right here hey
you know what it's time to bust out the
savage of debt he's been quiet over here
you don't bother nobody
this guy is a [__] real trooper he
hasn't said a word since day one Liv he
just sits there waiting for somebody
long month
let's clean this [__] right here
listen what are you gonna watch [__]
three men on a baby
give me a [__] break all right uncle
Joey's here to save the day
let's hit this Paris again it seems to
be working
I am [__] fizzled on this day and you
know you got how long I know you
[__] for my eyes to be for
sizzle I also did about nine pockets we
could have killed the whole [__]
Syrian army fight with this [__]
thing I'm saying what they did they won
the [__] thing to get today how many
bombs they dropped with it what they
bring us tryouts
they were back on the [__] na I'm the
[__] that thing flying planes again
this weed was a dumb war gets a serious
drop this off for the parachute what are
you [__] kidding me go back two days
later they're out there laying there
with their eyes blinking
that's right Joey Diaz takes down
serious solo chemical warfare look at
his [__] look you see Lee's hat when he
smoked this - blew up his head wait give
that what's unable to press on it Assad
give him a bong hit of this it's all
over
you could bitch-slap them to death you
give a [__] slap somebody to death it's
not a pretty scene
[Music]
the savage is on fire tonight
[__] this is better than a
Godzilla movie look at this [__]
thing
what are you nuts he's available for
parties the lychee has whole clean and
you can wash it with hello douchey calm
it's a complete [__] night list of
Pink Floyd they even threw the [__]
saxophone in there to throw you all what
what what if you had an ice cube in you
right now a sugar cube with some liquid
CID and you hear this [__] saxophone
but they don't stop
she Pink Floyd doesn't stop they was
rightness they were rightness [__] on
the sit of debt why they gonna show up
would [__] some sound effects and a
bunch of craziness you follow me this is
the beauty of Pink Floyd you wanna know
why I'm [__] crazy uh cuz I got hit
in the head with a safe one time when I
was robbing enjoy only tell what
happened well that was [__] 16 I used
to take ass and go home and listen to
this [__] with the lights out with your
phones on that the psychological damage
that's abused to yourself you understand
me some people cut themselves and stab
themselves no no no no I used to take a
hit of acid put some [__] speakers on
to a couple of roots a couple Baca beans
and I [__] lay there
listen to this whole album at night
going through psychological changes I'd
be giggling by myself and crying laughs
and then I'd have my confidence it's
[__] up what the [__] tells you these
things don't bother [__] you think
I don't get jealous not pay our [__]
sticks but no uncle Joey comes claiming
you [__] that's my got problems I did
because your mind isn't even [__]
developed and you [__] put initiative
to head what would he do to in the
fourth
this is deep Isis cab myself I wanted to
feel like somebody was chasing you know
what that feelings like I still do it
sometimes sometimes I eat 2000
milligrams and go home and I don't get
paranoid but I know somebody's chasing
me
I won't buy 10 [__] calories I'll sit
right there but I know somewhere
somebody's running around a corner
looking for me
there you go welcome my son to the
Machine you understand me
these something you guys could handle
this today I'll come over yes I know it
is liquid sit I'll turn the [__]
lights off and I'll put this Aleman
back-to-back-to-back-to-back by the
third time you'll be tapping on Yugi
Joey please call the psychotherapist
call the psychiatrist I need out for the
jackal out me tie me up people can't
take this [__] no more this's business
people feels is like the lunch
[Music]
too much if you didn't weapons of it
it's like just the basis
you didn't like school and you know you
nobody's fool oh [__] oh [__]
so welcome what
you think I show up for the Fugazi any
people on Monday night I respect you
[__] you thing on the shop with
cheap trades or something like that but
the [__] you think I'm gonna show
through what it's not even the holidays
that's what I really go crazy I see me
right now he scratched at beer you say
Fidel and Copernicus all rolled up into
one
make a wolf man didn't condition is big
you don't say
you got a condition you big you can't be
walking on a wolfy light no conditioning
it looks like that back they found in
the saddle in [__] Pennsylvania I'm
surprised you didn't bump into that
[__] back this [__]
would have bumped into a bat it's a
little mini he's like Ozzy jr. he can't
commit he fingers 21 shots he can't
breathe on the bomb nothing only you
would find thank God they shipped it if
they were gonna ship that here you would
have found that [__] better what's
the story people it's a beautiful night
write your goals figure 22 push-ups for
a vet [__] like walking together I
got [__] to do tomorrow you'll catch me
tomorrow I'm doing Doug [__] show
what else what else I got a meeting what
else I got an audition you know my days
complete come on what the [__] but I'm
gonna keep it together they keep focused
I gotta go home come and look at my
sides I'm gonna get up early look at my
sides you know we do it done always well
I'll be able to [__] touch our
[__]
but we're [__] my team delray that
time oh my god
you [__] you take a deal sharply enough
this reefer from a friend of mine he's a
girl and here's the [__] I don't mean no
[__] I got references I'm saying I
want references I want to see eyeballs I
want to see pictures of people on the
floor scattered and I'm saying like
[__] don't make me say it please you
know them [__] same anyway I love you
[__] gonna hit this podcast on
the back
[Music]
and guess should be here 15 I'm not
gonna tell you what it is you know make
know it is you're gonna love him in this
family when he gets here we'll do
another periscope to get the party
started and that's what we'll do and
that's it I've been thinking about you
[__] all things going where
they act then a fall little right little
don't text me don't text me in the case
of my text is broken I got text two days
later you know what and look at the
Mulenga what the [__] are these people
[__] I got text two days later I
don't pay attention attacks they go into
a different [__] envelope [__] unless
I go back there always should I had 19
thanks but I raise some more [__] you if
he didn't call me you [__] up your
saying anyway
[Music]
we think of this [__] Morgan here when
it's dark tonight and you know [__]
people on the other room
[Music]
you get all [__] up yeah
again
get in the back way
[Music]
when I do it I'll leave nothing
he's a [__] savage attack
don't forget to send the 17 send Lazarus
birthday jet December but you gotta be
ready now I'm saying you always got to
be ready for San lázaro especially if
you have a pet or a dog especially you
gotta be on point I'm saying you gotta
give San lázaro a little [__] suck
every year we think so anyway we're here
with Queen we'll be back in 15 minutes
youtube.com / c / Joey Diaz youtube.com
/ c / Joey Diaz I love you guys thank
you for [__] listening I'm gonna
surprise you don't worry about it